The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Everything
make sense?
Are you guys good with Newton?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, really?
I'm done.
I'm going home.
Are you guys good
with Karatsuba?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Kara-what?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so who is happy
with Karatsuba?
Good.
Who is happy with Newton?
Wait.
I need to ask the other ones,
because not enough people--
who is not happy with Newton
and wants to look over it?
Who wants to look
over Karatsuba?
Oh, so you guy are
paying attention.
Good.
OK.
All right.
So Newton and Karatsuba.
Let's start.
So Karatsuba real
fast, and then we'll
spend more time having
fun with Newton.
So suppose we don't
know Karatsuba.
We want to multiply two numbers.
What's the method that we
learned in elementary school?
AUDIENCE: You take the first
digit of the first number,
and then you multiply
it by the second number.
And then you take
the second digit
and multiply it by the second
number, but then you add a 0.
And so on and so forth.
PROFESSOR: So I'll
take this digit
and multiply it with this number
and write the result down here,
right?
So whatever this thing happens
to be, 1, 2, 3, 4 times 8,
write the result.
Then I take 1, 2, 3, 4 times
7 and add the result here
and the last digits are 0.
1, 2, 3, 4 times 6, two 0s.
1, 2, 3, 4 times 5, three 0s.
Then I add these up
and I know that I'm
going to get the right result.
What's the running
time for this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So why is it n squared?
AUDIENCE: Because you go
through every single thing
for every digit below.
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So I'll have these
partial products here,
and I have as many
partial products
as digits in the second number.
So if I have n digits here,
I have n partial products.
Each partial product is this
first number here multiplied
by a digit.
So if this guy has
n digits, then there
are n digits everywhere here.
And this thing will be
2 n insides actually,
but we're doing asymptotic,
so we don't really
care about constant factors.
So in the end, you have
to add up n numbers.
All of them are order n in size.
So n times order n squared.
This is plain old
multiplication.
Does anyone know why
Karatsuba's better?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You do
three multiplications
or something like that?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, let's go for
a simple answer.
AUDIENCE: It's better.
PROFESSOR: So the simpler
answer is it's faster.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: n, n log 2--
AUDIENCE: I said
better, it's faster.
PROFESSOR: I mean, some
algorithms have the same speed
but are simpler.
We like this one
because it's faster.
It's definitely not simpler.
So, it has this
running time here.
Log 2 of 3 is a weird number.
It's somewhere
between 1.5 and 2.
So not revolutionary, but
it's better than this guy.
OK, why do we get to this?
How do we get to this?
Does anyone remember
the recurrence for it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's 3 times 2--
PROFESSOR: You're
not remembering it.
You're cheating.
AUDIENCE: No, I'm not.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So, let's see
why it looks like this.
Karatsuba takes 2 numbers that
have n digits, splits both
of them up into two-- n over 2n,
n over 2, n over 2, n over 2--
and then is able to compute the
product of these two numbers
by only using three
multiplications, and then
some additions.
Multiplications are expensive,
additions are cheap.
So it does three multiplications
that are of the form
some number of n over
2 digits multiplied
by some number of
n over or 2 digits.
And exactly what the
multiplications and what
the additions are is, it's
interesting to look over it.
You can look over it, convince
yourself that this is correct.
Chances are you'll remember for
the exam and forget afterwards.
Please remember this.
This is the essence
of Karatsuba.
And remember Karatsuba,
because if you google this,
you get the rest.
So the multiplications
are in the notes.
I don't think it makes sense
to spend some time on them
and convince you
that, yeah, there
are three multiplications
that will get you that.
Instead, suppose I labeled
these as a, b, c, d.
If I evaluate the multiplication
as using brute force,
it's a times n over 2b plus
c-- sorry, a plus-- no,
this isn't good.
10 to the power n over 2a plus
b times 10-- assuming the base
is ten, if it's not, you
replace it-- n over 2 c plus d.
And you get 10 to the n
times, I think, ac plus 10
to the n over 2 times
ad plus bc plus bd.
The problem with this is
this is a multiplication,
multiplication,
multiplication, multiplication.
So this uses four
multiplications
of size n over 2 to
evaluate the answer one
multiplication of size n.
And if I have four
multiplications,
then the recursion becomes
4t of n over 2 plus o of n.
So this is t bad of n.
So if you do this using
the recursion tree,
you're going to see that--
yup, I hear whispers.
n squared.
So this isn't useful.
This will give you
insight on how to do it,
but if you try to
implement it this way,
you don't get any speed up.
The insight in Karatsuba
is that the guy figured out
how to do this with
three multiplications.
OK, makes sense?
Is everyone happy
with Karatsuba now?
So that multiplying by 10 to
the n over 2 is just shifting a?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
OK.
Very good point.
So this isn't an
actual multiplication.
If you have your number, say
stored in a python list--
so if these are
your digits, then
in order to multiply
by 10 to the n,
you append 10 to
the n 0s at the end.
0, 0, 0, 0, 0.
So, this is append of 0 n times.
So this is order n, so it
counts as an addition, not as
a multiplication.
So, these are free.
These are expensive.
1, 2, 3, 4.
OK.
Who's happy with Karatsuba now?
Let me feel like I did
something useful today.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I didn't fully
understand what [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So, I
have this number
and I'm splitting
it up into 2 halves.
The way split up is I say this
is a number of size n over 2,
and I have to shift
it to the left.
So n 10 to the power
of n over 2 shifts
it left by n over two digits.
And then I add it to b.
So this in a sense
is just saying
that this is the left half,
this is the right half.
AUDIENCE: This is
actually that same number.
PROFESSOR: Yup.
It's exactly the same number.
OK, so who is happy
with Karatsuba now?
AUDIENCE: Wait, but that's
four multiplications though.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: That's not three.
AUDIENCE: But we said
there were three.
PROFESSOR: So, I was
saying that this,
if you;re doing it the brute
force way, you get four,
and that is slow.
So what Karatsuba
did is he figured out
the way to do this with
just three multiplications.
So it's not these three.
You have to think
a little bit more.
But you google it, or you
look at the lecture notes,
or you think a little
bit, then you find out
the three multiplications
that do the trick.
So the difference between
this 4 here and this 3
here is important.
All right, anything
else on Karatsuba?
Cool.
Let's talk about Newton.
That's the hard stuff.
And let me see how
we're doing on time.
OK, doing well.
So does anyone remember
the point of Newton?
OK, so I heard an
application that
lets you compute square roots.
What else does it let you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, we have
Karatsuba for multiplication.
You might be able to
do it with Newton.
Probably not going to be faster.
But division, definitely.
So square roots and division.
So this is why we care about it.
Now what does it do from
a mathy perspective?
So what's the mathy
definition of Newton.
AUDIENCE: Estimates--
PROFESSOR: Estimates?
AUDIENCE: The value--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, we have a function.
Suppose it looks like this.
So, what Newton
helps us do is it
helps us find a root
of the function.
And the root is a value x 0
so that f of x 0 equals 0.
So this is what it does.
So when you want
to use Newton, you
have to set up your
function in such a way
that your answer is a root.
OK.
How does Newton work?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You
start at some point
where you actually
know the answer to it,
and then you kind of
draw a approximation.
So you're just drawing a line
from the point to the root,
and then just incrementing
down that line.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we start at
some point, right?
How do we call that point?
Initial guess.
Fancy name.
So we have an initial guess
for what the root might be.
It's not going to be the right
answer, because otherwise
why am I bothering with this?
But it can be too far off.
We'll say that if
you're too far off,
you're not going to
converge or you're not
going to converge fast enough.
So say we start somewhere
here and, we think, you know,
this is pretty close.
It's not quite there,
but it's pretty close.
What I do from here
on is, you said
I approximate this function--
AUDIENCE: The line.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So what's of the best line?
The best way to
approximate the function
with the line is to use
is the tangent, right?
So here, it sort
of looks like this.
And if the function
were linear, this
would be a perfect
approximation and we'd
get answer in one step.
OK.
So this is the tangent.
And then what we do
with this tangent?
AUDIENCE: Well, after we
get the equation for it,
then we find the root, right?
Or no?
PROFESSOR: Well, I can't
find the root right away.
AUDIENCE: The root of that line.
Of our tangent line.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we find the root
of the tangent, which
is the point where
it hits the x-axis.
And what happens
with this point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so this
is our next guess.
And then we trade.
So then we draw another
tangent, and the idea
is that eventually,
you're going to get there.
And if we go through
the maths, we
will see that you actually
get there pretty fast.
So that's why we
like this method.
So let's see how we convert this
drawing thing into an equation
that you can write into python.
Let's label these quantities.
So, x2, x1-- actually
let's not use 1 and 2,
because these are the
first two guesses.
Let's say our current guess is
x and the next guess is x prime.
So this line and is x1 minus
x, so this guy over here.
And what's this guy over here?
f of x.
Don't be shy.
It's the right answer.
So I have f of x here,
x 1 minus x here.
I also have this angle
here, and this angle here
is the same angle
as the angle here
because both of these
lines are horizontal,
so they're parallel.
So what do I know
about this angle?
AUDIENCE: It's tangent.
PROFESSOR: It's tangent.
OK.
The tangent, that's
called the angle alpha.
What's the tangent of the angle?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: F of x
over x [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I think
you're trying to give me
the formula for x prime.
Just the tangent.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Right?
Can someone reassure me?
This is right, right?
[AUDIENCE AGREES]
AUDIENCE: I was thinking
the slope of the line.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, yeah, you're
going to give me
the slope of the line
which lets me compute this.
OK, I was looking for this.
OK.
So now, let's get
what you're saying.
So this is the tangent, right?
So, the tangent at a
point of a function
is the function's derivative.
So now we're going to write
all these things down and hope
that we get an equation
that make sense.
So we have the
tangent of this guy,
also happens to
be this over this.
Right?
This is a right angle
triangle, so the tangent
is f of x over--
this is what you
were trying to tell me, right?
x1 minus x.
So now I know that
this is f prime of x.
OK.
So, we look at the picture,
we put in everything we know,
and then we write
an equation here.
And we solve for--
sorry, this is x prime.
So, if we solve
for x prime, we're
going to get x prime
as a function of x.
And this tells us,
given a guess here,
how do we compute
the next guess?
So once we have
an initial guess,
this lets us make the
guess better and better
and better, closer and
closer and closer to x0.
So, let's solve this
equation reasonably quickly.
x prime minus x equals f
prime of x over f of x, so
x prime is--
AUDIENCE: Does it matter if it's
x minus x prime or [INAUDIBLE],
because technically
it's x minus x prime.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
matters, because you're
going to get the wrong sign.
Which is exactly what
I'm about to do here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: So, I'm not
going very well, right?
This is wrong.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's because you
flipped your x at your prime--
AUDIENCE: x minus x prime
instead of x prime--
AUDIENCE: No, I think it's
because f prime of x is on top.
It should be on the bottom.
In the second--
no, third equation.
Shouldn't those be flipped?
Because if you move
the subtraction,
x prime to the left--
PROFESSOR: f what?
AUDIENCE: f of x over
f minus x instead
of f prime x over f of x.
Yeah, there you go.
PROFESSOR: OK, so I can do math.
OK, so that's one issue.
There's one more issue.
So, there are too
many issues here.
Issue number one, this.
Issue number two,
I got this wrong.
AUDIENCE: Oh, we get
a negative number.
AUDIENCE: 2x minus x prime.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So the reason for
that is we're going--
AUDIENCE: Only if you start
from the right, though.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you
start from the left,
if your guess is to the
left of the actual root,
it may or may not be different.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So our guess should
be to the right.
So this is x minus x prime.
So the reason it's x minus x
prime, the way you remember
this and you don't do the
same mistake that I did
is, you want to walk
against the derivative.
If you walk in the
direction of the derivative,
it's going to move
you forward, right?
So, if you go in the
direction of the derivative,
instead of going
backwards like this,
you're going to go
forward like this.
So you're going to go
away from the solution.
So, this will take us
in the right direction,
and this means that it's--
OK.
So two ways to remember this.
One that you're going
against the derivative.
Another one is that
you have your guess
and you're subtracting
something from it.
AUDIENCE: You flipped
your primes again.
PROFESSOR: Again?
Jesus.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I mean, I
agree, the prime looks
better on top part of
the fraction, but still.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well clearly, my hand
thinks the same thing.
So this is you'd
iterate using Newton.
So the way to remember
that the signs are right
is your x is somewhere
here, and you
know you have to subtract
something from it so it looks
like this figure.
And this actually works in
all the cases, turns out.
Our guesses are usually
smaller than the actual number,
and this still works.
OK, so let's go over Newton.
What do we have, or
what do we need in order
to make Newton happen.
So we need to be able
to evaluate this, right?
So we need to be
able to evaluate
f over f prime of x for
any x that Newton gives us.
And for Newton,
this is a black box.
So whichever way
you use to implement
this is fine, as long as
it works reasonably fast.
OK, what else do we
need to use Newton.
We need to remember this formula
Let's start with something
easy.
Suppose we want to use
it to compute a over b.
How do I do that?
What do I need?
AUDIENCE: You need a
line, a tangent line
like you did before.
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
already taken care of here.
So we have this, and
we know that we'll
have to compute this
and plug it in here.
So, what do I need to
compute a/b using Newton?
So, I need the function, right?
This thing.
I can't say it's something, I
have to figure out what it is.
I guess I was confusing because
I said assume we have this.
Well, sorry.
We don't have this.
We need to figure
out the function
so we can evaluate this.
OK, so we need to come
up with the function
so we can evaluate
that, and what property
does the function need to meet?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that
would be nice, right?
So we want the function
so that f of a/b equals 0,
because that's the number
that Newton will give us.
And we also need to be able
to compute f over f prime of x
without doing any
division, right?
If we did the divisions,
it doesn't work.
OK, so the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to simplify this
problem to 1 over b instead
of a over b, because if
you know what's 1 over b,
you're going to
multiply this by a,
and you're going
to get a over b.
Suppose we work
with integers and we
don't want to touch
floating point numbers.
What would we actually compute?
AUDIENCE: You shift
it out, right?
To get that 0.23, shift
now to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right, all right.
So 1 over b.
Unless b is 1, in which
case it's really boring.
1 over b looks like this.
0 point something.
This is not an integer number.
I don't like it.
So what I do is,
I decide that I'm
going to need
digits of precision,
and I'm going to shift
the decimal point
right by d digits.
So instead of 0
point something, it's
d digits here point
something else.
How do I do this?
AUDIENCE: Multiply
by 10 to the d?
PROFESSOR: Multiply
by 10 to the d.
So instead of computing 1
over b, 10 to the d over b.
And we call this 10 to the
d R in our station notes.
So we're going to compute
R. Over b multiplied
by a, and then
everything divided by R.
So we talked about
how you multiply
by R. How do you divide by R?
So, if I have a
number with n digits
and I want to divide by 10
to the d, how do I do that?
AUDIENCE: Shift.
PROFESSOR: Shift right.
If the number is a python list?
AUDIENCE: Slice it.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So kill the last d digits.
So, if I add d
digits to the right,
I multiply by 10 to the d.
If I slice the last digits,
I divide by 10 to the d.
So this is division,
this is multiplication.
And the reason I care
about that is this
is going to be an easy division,
and whenever I have this,
it's an easy multiplication.
OK, now what function
am I going to use?
Does anyone know?
Can I use x minus R
over b equals zero?
AUDIENCE: Sure?
PROFESSOR: Well, so, this is
f of x. f prime of x is what?
AUDIENCE: Just
negative R over b.
Or no, 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, f prime of x over--
AUDIENCE: I think you
switched it again.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Because I was running ahead,
and I was like, OK, this works.
Why does it work?
OK, so this is going to be
x minus R over b, right?
Can you evaluate this?
If I can't evaluate this,
I already know the answer.
AUDIENCE: Your prime's
not on the bottom one.
PROFESSOR: So, it's x
minus this divided by 1.
So, it's this.
So then, if you're trying to
evaluate this far the guesses
that Newton gives
you, you can't.
Because if you could, you'd
have the answer already.
So we can't use this function.
This is a nice and easy
function that doesn't work.
So while I erase the
board, one minute, someone
figure out the right function.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Man,
that's hard math.
No, that's too hard.
That's too hard.
OK, let's try this.
Let's try instead
of x minus R over b,
let's try this 1/x minus b/R.
And the intuition behind this
is if I have to compute
b/R, I can do that.
Right?
It's an easy division.
If I somehow get rid of
1/x and all I have to do
is compute b/R, it's
an easy division.
Because dividing by
2 to the R by R means
you're going to shift by
some digits to the right.
So let's see if the math
works out for this function.
What's f prime of x?
AUDIENCE: Negative
1 over x prime?
PROFESSOR: All right.
Like, does no one know it?
At least one student
has to know it.
OK, so f of x divided
by f prime of x is what?
AUDIENCE: Negative x
plus x squared b/R.
PROFESSOR: Plus x squared b R.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Is this right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if I have my initial guess--
so if I want to get x prime,
x prime is x minus f of x
over f prime of x, right?
So, what is it?
AUDIENCE: 2x minus x
squared over R. OK.
Did this work?
Did it get rid of all
the hard divisions?
[LAUGHS]
Please nod so I know
we're good to go.
Tell me if we're not.
So how many divisions
did we have here?
One division, this guy, right?
AUDIENCE: But that's a shift.
PROFESSOR: That's a shift.
Because R is 10 to the d.
AUDIENCE: What about the
multiplication [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So, we know
how to do multiplication
because we learned
Karatsuba just now.
So we wanted to get
rid of division,
because if you're
trying to solve division
by doing division,
it's probably not
I'm going to work unless you're
doing divide and conquer.
OK, so this is how it works.
I'm not going to run into
the error formulas for this
because I want to do
another case first.
You can keep going on this
and it's in the notes.
The only thing that
is useful to remember
is that we use this trick.
So, I want to look at this
function, square root 3 of a,
and I want to use
Newton to compute it.
So this is the third order root.
It's not the regular square
root that we had before.
So we're trying to
not be boring and not
just repeat what's in the notes.
How do I do this?
Let's walk through the steps.
So what's the first
thing that we do?
Very good.
Look to the right.
Find the first step,
and let's put it here.
What's the first step.
AUDIENCE: Function f
of 0 at cube root of a.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we need a function
f so that f of-- good.
So before we start writing
the actual function,
what if I want to
compute cube root
of a up to d digits
of precision?
So if I want to
compute cube root of 2,
this is going to give me
numbers that are below 1.
I have to do with
fractions again.
I don't like that.
If I want the digits of
precision, what do I do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Jumping ahead.
But yeah.
So you have the right answer,
but you're speaking slowly
because you're afraid you're
going to do a mistake, right?
So, the way to compute this
to d digits of precision 10
to the d, right?
This shifts the
dot to the right.
So I have to get this
10 to the d inside here,
and I get and to the 3d times a.
Perfect answer, by the way.
Don't forget this 3 here.
If you do, you're going
to get something else.
So now I take this guy,
and this is the new number
whose cube root I
have to compute.
Cube, cube, cube.
OK.
So I can do this
in integer land,
and then I'll get
an integer result,
and I shift it
right by d digits,
and I have a number with
d digits of precision.
Does this make sense?
OK, what's f?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's go for that.
Let's see if that works.
x cubed minus a.
Well, let's pretend.
We're going to make
this b the new a.
So let's not to
worry about this.
This happens somewhere else.
We went through
it so that we know
that we know how
to deal with it.
And now we're going
to forget about it.
So, it's x cubed minus a.
Because we argued that
this is an integer, right?
So we don't have to do anything
fancy like dividing by R
that we had to do over there.
So, what's f prime of x?
OK.
So, iteration?
How do we iterate?
AUDIENCE: x prime?
PROFESSOR: Let's start
with x prime equals
x minus f of x
over f prime of x.
Right?
Nice and easy so
we have it here.
And this becomes minus copy
these two things, right?
x cubed minus a over 3x squared.
OK.
Next thing, I bring this
guy under the denominator,
so it's 3x cubed minus x
cubed plus a over 3x squared.
So it's 2x cubed plus
a over 3x squared.
So this is 2/3 plus--
AUDIENCE: 2 over 3x.
You keep saying
cubed and writing 2.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's better.
Thank you.
Plus 1/3 times a over x.
So this one's division.
AUDIENCE: x squared.
PROFESSOR: x squared.
Ouch.
So this guy wants division.
By the time I do this, I better
have division ready, right?
OK, so that my iteration.
x prime is 2/3 x plus
1/3 and a over x squared.
What else do I need?
An initial guess
would be nice, right?
I can't do this if I
don't have the first x.
So let's try to think of a
starting x that's reasonable.
The better it is, the
faster it's going to be.
So let's try to come up with
something reasonable that
doesn't require too much
thinking or too much.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Too much work.
I have to compute a square root.
So what's a?
Let's start with that.
What's an a, right?
So, it's an n digit number.
And say the digits are d1,
d2, d3, all the way up to dn.
So what's a good approximation?
Well, the first
approximation for this?
AUDIENCE: You get a
third as many digits.
PROFESSOR: A third
as many digits.
OK.
So something times
10 to the n/3.
Let's say that
something is 1, right?
So this is the
first approximation.
It's the right
order of magnitude.
Do people see why this
is a good approximation?
So this number,
whatever it is, it
has to be between 1,
0, 0 0, 0, and 1, 0, 0.
OK.
So generally when
we do this, what
we have to have in
an approximation
is the right order of magnitude
And maybe the first digit.
If we can figure
out the first digit,
then we're in a good
shape, or something really
close to the first digit.
How would we get
the first digit?
AUDIENCE: Cube root
of the first digit?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Sure.
How do we compute this?
AUDIENCE: Get a formula?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so I'm not
going to argue with that.
AUDIENCE: I like that.
PROFESSOR: So I want to reject
the recursive argument first.
So this is going
to be small, right?
This is going to be 10 if
you're working with digits,
or if you're a computer,
maybe it's 256,
or maybe it's 2 to
the 16 or 2 to the 32.
Not much bigger
than that, right?
Pretty small.
So these algorithms really
good for big numbers.
Algorithms that are
complicated but have
nice asymptotic complexity
are good for big numbers.
They're awful for small numbers,
as in they 10 to 100 times
more times to run.
So let's not to
do that for this,
because it's like
bringing a tank
and shooting it so you
can hammer a nail in.
Not the right tool.
So, precomputed list.
I like that.
It's an option, especially
if you're [INAUDIBLE] right?
You can use pen and
paper to get it.
What if I don't want to do that.
What if my base is
more like this.?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this is
a very good solution.
I'm not arguing with it.
If your power is this or this,
by all means, use a table.
So let's see what do we do here?
I just want to think
a little bit more.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so there's
some approximation
that comes from math
that says that d1 over 3
is not going to be
such a bad guess.
Now let's be CS people
and do something better.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the exponent.
2 to the 14, divide--
is that 14, right here
AUDIENCE: 16.
Divide 16 by 3.
Or I guess that's not
quite right either.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying
2 to the power of, say, 5?
15 over 3?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
seem quite right.
PROFESSOR: So, let's
try to do better.
This is math.
Let's just try to
do it in a CS way.
So we're trying to guess a
digit between 0 and 2 to the 16.
I heard an "oh."
Yes?
You had your hand up?
No?
OK.
AUDIENCE: You take the
current time 2 to the 16.
I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So your
algorithm is going
to be fast with some
probability, right?
No, that's terrible.
Let's not do that.
Please don't make me
grade code like that.
AUDIENCE: Did you already
cut out the recursive option?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, so I don't want to
recurse on square roots.
AUDIENCE: But you could
recurse on that one.
PROFESSOR: I mean,
if you give me
some algorithm that happens--
AUDIENCE: You're
already [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, what's the intuition?
If you have a computer
and you have register,
bytes, bits, whatever.
You don't know how
to do square roots.
That's not an instruction, but
these are all instructions.
Right?
So if I have a guess,
say I start with half
and then I get my guess, what
do I need for the binary search
to work?
Given a guess that's
somewhere here,
I have to be able to say whether
this is too small, too big,
or just the right number.
So given a guess, I can multiply
it by itself three times,
right?
Compute gets cubed.
And I can see how does
it compare to the number
that I want.
So I have the first digit, and
I have an order of magnitude.
Not bad, right?
Pretty good initial guess.
This is as much of an answer
is you need to give out
in physics problems, and you
get full score, so that's good.
OK, how are we doing so far?
Following along?
AUDIENCE: If we compute
our guess cubed,
we want only to compare
it to our original number
to see how close it is?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
AUDIENCE: And, do we just
keep on doing that until--
PROFESSOR: Well, so you're going
have to guess a digit, right?
Between 0 and 2 to the 16.
So you choose the largest thing
that's smaller than your guess,
or something.
AUDIENCE: Or until we
get the first digit.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just the first.
And then you have a
first digit, and then you
have an order of magnitude.
And then you feed
that to Newton,
which converges way faster.
So you could the binary
search for the whole thing,
but that would be slower
than Newton, turns out.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So where'd
you get the f of x here?
I'm missing that stuff.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, right there.
PROFESSOR: Someone
told me to use this.
[LAUGHTER]
One of you guys
told me to use this.
Well, so I tried it out.
I put it here.
And then I computed
the derivative,
and I looked to see if
this looks reasonable.
And this looks like
something I can compute.
AUDIENCE: And why
was that reasonable?
PROFESSOR: Because I know
how to do the division
and multiplication.
So, say if I would have had
the square root of 3 in here,
that wouldn't be
reasonable, right?
Just like before.
When you're trying
to compute division,
we can't have division.
If you're trying to
compute sine of x,
you don't want to
have sine of x.
AUDIENCE: OK.
and computing a over x
squared is reasonable?
PROFESSOR: Because
we did it before.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So then you might use
something else, maybe?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can use something else as
long as you know how to do it,
and as long as it's
reasonably fast.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, no that's fine.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that fine?
OK.
PROFESSOR: So, the
binary search is
fine to get the
first approximation.
But after that--
so I'm not going
to do a binary search
for the whole result,
because Newton is
faster than that.
I'm just using this so
that I have a decent guess
to pass to Newton.
And we'll see why we need that
decent guess in two minutes
total.
So I'm going to try to
spend two minutes to explain
how the error thing
works, and you'll
have to look at the
notes and make sense out
of the rest of it.
So, let's see.
Errors.
So with Newton, you start
to with an initial guess,
and then you get to a
better guess, and a better
guess, and a better guess,
and so on and so forth
until you're satisfied.
By the way, if we're doing
this one, are we satisfied?
AUDIENCE: What do you mean,
like, finding the guess?
Are we satisfied?
PROFESSOR: Oh, no.
So, we have the initial guess.
And we keep applying the formula
that I just deleted to iterate.
When do we stop?
AUDIENCE: When we have
enough digits of precision?
PROFESSOR: So how do we know
when we have enough digits,
if we're working with integers?
AUDIENCE: We iterate
again and nothing changes.
PROFESSOR: We iterate
So I'm computing-- do
I have this anywhere?
Oh, no.
I erased it.
So I'm computing 10 t0
some-- oh, I had it up here.
So, I'm computing
10 to the power
of d times a square
root of 3, because I
want to work with integers.
Just integers.
I used Newton to iterate.
My precision gets gets
better and better and better.
And I use integers.
So I only have d
digits of precision.
Everything after that gets
discarded automatically.
When I get 2 x's that don't
change-- so if I get x5,
and then I run
the thing and then
I get x6 that is
equal to x5, there's
no point to keep
running Newton, right?
I;m stuck.
And I'm also done
because I have the answer
with d digits of precision.
So this is where I stop.
OK.
Now, my precision is how far
I am from the right answer.
And we write that
by saying that x1
is x, the true answer, times
1 plus epsilon, epsilon 1.
And then x2 is x times 1 plus
epsilon 2, 1 plus epsilon 3,
so on and so forth.
Right?
So, if we had a lot of time
and not too much stuff to do,
I could copy this thing here
that we have in the notes.
That's eight lines of math.
And then we'd get something
along the lines of x of i
plus 1 is x times 1
plus something times E
squared-- I'm sorry, Ei squared.
So this is also
1 plus Ei plus 1.
So what we get is that E of i
plus 1 is roughly E i squared.
And this is what's really
called quadratic convergence.
Now why is this good?
Can anyone think intuitively
why this is nice?
In which cases?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You're converging
really quickly to your answer.
PROFESSOR: OK.
But when do I converge?
, So what I want this to happen?
What do I want this to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, you
guys told me everything
I need for the next two minutes.
So, I want this to
become 1, right?
This has to go to 1 because I
want this whole thing to be x.
So in order for this to be 1,
I want to epsilons to go to 0.
So I want them to be
as small as possible.
Now, you said that if my
epsilon is smaller than 1,
then epsilon squared is
smaller than epsilon.
And intuitively,
how this works is,
suppose you start with
an epsilon of 0.1.
When you square
it, you get 0.01.
You square it again,
you get 0.0001.
Square it again.
0.00000001.
OK.
This is step 0, step
1, step 2, step 3.
How many digits do I have here?
Don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: 2 to the i?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
2 to the i.
So this is going
to be equal to this
when 1 plus x times 1 plus
epsilon i over 1 plus epsilon--
sorry, i plus 1 epsilon i
when the floor of this thing
is-- sorry, there is a
delta somewhere here.
So, something has
to converge to 0.
Sorry, this is what it is.
1 plus e of i.
So this is the difference
between two terms, x.
So this is x6 minus x5, right?
Convincing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Let's write it again.
This is out of hand.
So, x, x minus x5,
or actually, xi
plus 1 minus xi is equal
to x times 1 plus epsilon i
plus 1 minus x times 1
plus epsilon i, right?
So this is x times-- Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Those are xi, x of i.
AUDIENCE: No, those
are the real x's.
PROFESSOR: These are-- so
these are the approximations,
but then, this is the real x.
AUDIENCE: I
understand, thank you.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, this is, the difference
between them is this guy here.
So if I take the floor
because I work with integers,
when this floor becomes
0, we're done, right?
So in order for the
floor to become 0,
this guy has to be
canceled by this guy.
So this guy has some number
of digits, whatever that is.
It's my number with d
digits of precision.
Well, that's OK
because-- where my 0s?
Did I erase my 0s?
Oh, no.
I have 0s here, right?
The epsilons have a
lot of 0s in them,
so the 0s are going to
cancel the digits in x.
So as soon as I have enough 0s
here to cancel this, I'm stuck.
The number of 0s
increases exponentially.
So in each step the number
of 0s I have doubles.
So after log d steps, I'm done.
If I have d digits
in here, because I'm
computing this with d
digits of precision,
after roughly log d steps,
I'll have enough 0s here
to reduce this and make
the whole thing be 0.
So this is how I
know that it's fast.
So in the end, what you
want is the initial guess
has to satisfy
this, and then you
want to be able to
prove that this is true.
So you want this factor
here that tells you you're
converging fast.
So when you look at
the recitation notes
and you look at this
long string of equations,
make sure this is
somewhere there,
because this means you're
on the right track.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If it
takes log d steps,
doesn't the binary search
also take log-- ah, OK.
Log 10 steps.
Got it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Which is d.
AUDIENCE: He's talking
about binary search--
PROFESSOR: Oh, for one digit.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I thought you meant
for the whole thing.
So if you wanted to do binary
search for the whole thing,
that's log of the whole number.
So that's order d where d
is the number of digits.
AUDIENCE: Wait, he's talking
about a binary [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] wants
to go for [INAUDIBLE], 10
to the 20th.
He wants to do a binary
search over like a cube root--
PROFESSOR: So, for this?
Binary search for
this or for one digit?
Or binary search to
compute the cube root?
AUDIENCE: I think, yeah.
PROFESSOR: So, if you do
that, your entire thing is
d digits, right?
So 10 to the d.
Binary search takes
log of 10 to the d.
AUDIENCE: Right, yeah.
PROFESSOR: So the
numbers that we're
dealing with are d digits.
So this d is the number
of digits, not the number
that you have.
So if you look at the
number that you have,
this is log log n.
AUDIENCE: Right,
that makes sense.
Sorry.
PROFESSOR: So, it's faster.
AUDIENCE: I like it.
It is faster.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Cool.
Thanks for the lesson.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].